[Musik]
die Erde war schon vor uns da und wird
noch lange nach uns da sein
alle Lebewesen auf ihr haben sich über
Äonen hinweg gemeinsam entwickelt
[Musik]
und obwohl wir Teil des Netzes des
Lebens sind
weil wir es sehen
denken wir dass wir über ihm stehen
[Musik]
aus all dem was die Natur uns gegeben
hat haben wir eine neue Welt aus der
Wildnis geschaffen
errichteten große Zivilisationen
es schien als gäbe es nichts was wir
nicht tun könnten
nicht einmal der Himmel selbst war die
Grenze
wir sehen die Symptome einer Realität
die wir nicht erwartet haben
haben wir die Grenzen unserer
menschlichen Natur erreicht
ist dies das Ende der Fahnenstange für
uns
aus unserer heutigen Sicht die wir hier
in der Vergangenheit der Zukunft leben
ist das schwer zu sagen
die Welt in der wir leben ist einfach
eine schockierend blaue Kugel
wenn man sie im Weltraum sieht versteht
man dass es ein Planet ist der um die
Sonne kreist und sich um die eigene
Achse dreht die Ozeane die Wolken die
Berge die Wälder all das kann man von
dort oben sehen man kann über 1.000
Meilen in jede Richtung sehen und das
alles bewegt sich mit fünf Meilen pro
Sekunde unter einem
wenn sie auf den Horizont schauen sehen
sie ein sehr sehr dünnes blaues Band der
Atmosphäre
für mich und ich bin Wissenschaftler ich
dachte ich hätte alles intellektuell
begriffen aber es war ein Schock für
mich zu sehen wie dünn die Atmosphäre
ist und wie leicht Sie durch unser
Handeln beeinflusst wird
das ist die große Herausforderung
unserer Zeit wenn es um die Auswirkungen
des Menschen auf die Umwelt geht und was
dies für die Zukunft unserer
Zivilisation bedeutet
wir fällen alle Bäume wir töten alle
Fische
wir konsumieren und konsumieren
so viele ökologische Texte schlagen Sie
einfach die Zeitungen auf handeln vom
Ende der Welt es geht los aber wann geht
es los frage ich mich in 3 2 1 und der
Begriff Welt als eine Art
Unterscheidungsmerkmal zwischen die
Menschen und allem anderen hat sich
aufgelöst
das ist der einzige Ort im ganzen
Universum denen wir kennen indem wir
leben können
das Leben ist chaotisch wir verändern
zahlreiche Aspekte der Umwelt der Erde
die Vorhersage alle Auswirkungen ist
unglaublich kompliziert
und was tun wir wir lehnen uns zurück
und schauen der Natur bei ihren
Niedergang zu
wir alle fragen uns warum tun wir nicht
mehr dagegen wir haben unsere
Fähigkeiten genutzt um eine riesige
technologische Gesellschaft aufzubauen
die sehr fortschrittlich ist aber im
Grunde genommen sind wir immer noch
Tiere und eines der Probleme ist dass
wir als Tiere bestimmte Emotionen und
bestimmte Tendenzen haben die in unserer
großen komplexen Gesellschaft
kontraproduktiv sind
der Philosoph spinosa hat gesagt der
Mensch versteht nicht wirklich alle
unbewussten Prozesse die seine bewussten
Verhaltensweisen und Gedanken steuern
vielleicht beginnen die Lösungen nach
denen wir suchen in uns selbst in
unseren Genen in unseren Unterbewussten
Motivationen unseren ursprünglichsten
Instinkten
wir sind die flexibelste Spezies die
sich je entwickelt hat denke ich wenn
man sich ansieht wie Menschen in der
Arktis und in der Kalahari Wüste
gedeihen
und im Amazonas Regenwald das sind
gigantische Leistungen
aber wir haben auch die Möglichkeit all
diese Lebensräume zu zerstören und alles
was dazwischen liegt
kann es uns helfen die Evolution zu
betrachten um unser gegenwärtiges
Bewusstsein und die Zukunft der
Menschheit zu verstehen
[Musik]
aus der Sicht der Evolution ist der
Mensch nur eine von vielen Spezies wir
sind einzigartig aber die
Evolutionsbiologie sieht jeder Art als
einzigartig an
jede Spezies egal wo ist ein
überlebensgenie sonst gäbe es sie nicht
jeder Art kann uns etwas lehren
wenn man sich all die Tiere und Pflanzen
ansieht scheinen sie so unterschiedlich
zu sein aber natürlich sind wir alle aus
demselben Stoff die Atome aus denen die
Moleküle bestehen die die DNA
hervorbringen und ihre Vielfalt haben
den Prozess der natürlichen Selektion in
Gang gesetzt wir wissen also dass die
natürliche Auslese dieser Vielfalt
diejenigen ermöglicht hat die für die
jeweilige Umgebung am besten geeignet
sind
die natürliche Selektion hat
verschiedene Organismen Stämme
hervorgebracht und wir stehen an der
Spitze eines dieser Stimme
die Tatsache dass wir Tiere sind
bedeutet nicht dass wir unter unserer
hochentwickelten Zivilisation diese
utilitaristischen Klumpen sind sondern
genau das Gegenteil es bedeutet dass das
Anspruchsdenken und die Kunstfertigkeit
ganz nach unten Zurückgehen auf die
Ebene von Käfern mit schülernden
Flügeldecken
denn es gibt etwas von Natur aus nicht
utilitaristisches und spielerisches in
der Evolution
wir sind Teil des Systems wir sind die
Natur wir sind Teil der Erde und wir
sind grundsätzlich von ihrem Wohlwollen
abhängig eine sehr symbiotische
Beziehung zu allem auf dieser Erde
und ich verstehe einige Leute die sagen
nein nein diese Wissenschaft ist nichts
für uns das ist Sache Gottes das sollten
wir nicht anrühren ich kann diese
Ansicht verstehen aber ich glaube nicht
dass ich sie in der Heiligen Schrift
wiederfinde
was ich in der Schrift sehe ist dass ich
es euch zeigen will dass ich mich euch
offenbaren möchte
ich sehe die Wissenschaft nicht als
Herausforderung für meinen Glauben
sondern als Bestätigung
wir sind neu auf dem Planeten wir sind
die am weitesten entwickelten wir sind
ein Probelauf in der Evolution passen
sich die Tiere an ihre ökologischen
Bedingungen an aber als Menschen haben
wir es geschafft unsere ökologischen
Bedingungen zu kontrollieren
die Evolution selbst ist ein Prozess
durch den Organismen effizienter werden
wenn es darum geht Ressourcen aus ihrer
Umwelt zu gewinnen was den Menschen von
allen anderen Tieren unterscheidet ist
seine Beherrschung der Technik wir sind
auf einzigartige Weise in der Lage
unsere Umwelt auf eine Weise zu
verändern die es kein anderes Tier kann
wir Menschen sind in Wirklichkeit
großhändige Primaten die das Glück
hatten auf zwei Beinen zu stehen und
herauszufinden wie man andere Tiere aus
der Ferne erlegen kann indem man etwas
auf sie schmeißt
wir haben herausgefunden wie wir das
Feuer zähmen und es zu unserem Vorteil
nutzen unsere sich entwickelnde
Technologie ermöglicht es uns in neue
Gebiete vorzudringen und die Umwelt zu
manipulieren auf eine Weise die uns
einen Vorteil verschaffte
Orte wie dieser erinnern mich daran wie
rau die Natur sein kann wir sind so
daran gewöhnt mit Klimaanlagen zu leben
und den Komfort der modernen Welt zu
haben aber wenn man in die Natur geht
und sie aus erster Hand erlebt wird man
sehr eindringlich daran erinnert wie
schwach wir als Tiere sind
[Musik]
und das liegt daran dass wir im Grunde
eine kulturelle Spezies sind
Kultur ist unser Lebenserhaltungssystem
unsere kumulative Kultur ermöglicht es
uns und sein Polster gegen die harte
Welt anzulegen und die Umwelt neu zu
gestalten
unsere Kultur ist ein integraler
Bestandteil unserer Ökologie wir können
unsere menschlichen Vorfahren über 4
Millionen Jahre zurückverfolgen und den
anatomisch moderne Menschen über 200.000
Jahre und wir haben seine besten
überlebensmerkmale geehrt
diese Eigenschaften sind in gewissem
Maße in jedem von uns vorhanden wie zum
Beispiel die Optimierung der Zeit sich
wirklich darum zu kümmern was andere
Leute über uns denken und uns mit
anderen zu vergleichen
[Musik]
wir versuchen immer noch täglich den
gleichen emotionalen Zustand zu
erreichen wir unsere erfolgreichen
Vorfahren
wir tragen dieselben Neurotransmitter in
unserem Gehirn die bei unseren Vorfahren
das berauschende Gefühl auslösten wenn
sie unerwartet eine Beere oder eine Nuss
gefunden haben oder sich auf eine
erfolgreiche Jagd gefreut haben
aber in einer Kultur der erstaunlichen
Technologie sind wir von Anreizen
umgeben die uns dazu bringen uns zu
belohnen
unsere evolutionären Impulse können
leicht gekapert werden
unabhängig davon wo auf der Welt man
aufgewachsen ist liegt es in unserer DNA
die Menschen um uns herum zu kopieren
für den Menschen ist die Nachahmung ein
fester Bestandteil seiner Stammes
Zugehörigkeit
jetzt passen wir uns vor allem an das
kulturelle Umfeld an dass wir um uns
herum geschaffen haben wenn wir nicht in
unsere Kultur passen werden wir uns
nicht vermehren und nicht gut überleben
können
wir würden geächtet werden und in einer
sozialen Spezies wieder unseren geächtet
zu werden kann sich wie ein Todesurteil
anfühlen
haben wir ein menschliches Gehirn das
nicht richtig funktioniert eine fehlende
Übereinstimmung in der Art und Weise wie
wir uns entwickelt haben und den
modernen Umständen in denen wir uns
befinden sind unsere Bedürfnisse anders
als die unserer Vorfahren
das Wort Bedürfnis kann ein starkes
Verlangen bedeuten z.B ich brauche
unbedingt eine Tafel Schokolade und es
tut mir leid aber ich bin mir sicher
dass die Neandertaler Coca-Cola Zero
geliebt hätten sie sahen wirklich gut
und rein aus weil sie es nicht hatten
aber das sind wir am Schlucker
vermutlich hatten sie das gleiche
Nervensystem wenn es stimmt dass auch
die Neandertaler süchtig nach Angry
Birds geworden wären es gibt etwas
Wahres in der heutigen Gesellschaft die
heutige Gesellschaft sagt etwas Wahres
über Menschen von früher aus
[Musik]
das ist das Gehirn eines modernen
Menschen und so weit wir wissen ist es
identisch mit dem Gehirn von Menschen
die vor 50.000 Jahren lebten aber
natürlich sind die Informationen die
modern Gehirn gespeichert sind ganz
anders als bei unseren Vorfahren das
Gehirn codiert im Grunde genommen
Informationen und diese Informationen
ändern sich von einer Generation zur
nächsten sie können also den Verlauf der
menschlichen Evolution als die Anhäufung
von Weisheit und Wissen sehen die wir
von einer Generation an die nächste
weitergeben
unser Wahrnehmungssystem ist nicht auf
die massiven Veränderungen eingestellt
die auf dem Planeten vor sich gehen sie
sind auch nicht auf die sehr feinen
Details dieser Veränderungen eingestellt
das Alarmsystem unseres Gehirns für
Bedrohungen die er mögtaler die
emotionalen Zentren sind sehr
empfänglich für diese früheren Gefahren
aus einer Zeit in der das Rascheln im
Gebüsch ein Tiger sein konnte werde ich
fressen wollte oder die heutigen
symbolischen Realitäten ich werde nicht
mehr behandelt oder Schatz wir müssen
reden oder was auch immer der Auslöser
für Sie ist
wir haben ein sehr schnelles System das
sozusagen mit Bauchgefühlen arbeitet mit
reflexartigen Reaktionen mit einer
sofortigen Reaktion auf Gefahren
auf der anderen Seite haben wir ein
langsameres die liberatives System das
Zeit braucht um sich zu engagieren und
das langsam und schwerfällig ist so dass
wir uns mit komplexen Themen in der
Umwelt um uns herum beschäftigen sollten
wir sind physische und biologische Wesen
die in einem Ozean aus kosmischer
Energie leben
das klingt ziemlich abgefahren und das
ist es auch
wo jedes Teil Informationen über das
ganze enthält
der lange Blick ist sowohl nach vorne
als auch nach hinten gerichtet
[Musik]
während 99,9% unserer
Evolutionsgeschichte waren wir Jäger und
Sammler und lebten in kleinen Gruppen
von Verwandten wo jeder mit jedem
verwandt war und wir daher einen
berechtigtes Interesse daran hatten
füreinander zu sorgen wir haben auch so
gelebt dass wir die Tragfähigkeit des
Bodens nicht überschritten haben
es gab keine Möglichkeit Lebensmittel
über längere Zeiträume zu lagern und
somit auch keine Möglichkeit Überschüsse
zu erwerben dies führte zu einem sehr
egalitären Gesellschaftssystem in dem
Frauen Autonomie hatten es gab unter den
Menschen keine wirklich starre Dominanz
Hierarchie und erst nach der Erfindung
des Ackerbaus und der Domestizierung von
Pflanzen und Tieren stand der Mensch vor
der Frage was er mit diesen
überschüssigen Ressourcen anfangen
sollte
[Musik]
das war der Beginn der neolitischen
Revolution wir begannen zum ersten Mal
mit der Landwirtschaft von daher nahm
alles seinen Lauf und das ist erst seit
etwa 12000 Jahren der Fall das ist
evolutionär gesehen ein Wimpernschlag
die Kontrolle über die Produktion und
Verteilung dieser überschüssigen
Ressourcen führte zu einem Wandel in der
kulturellen und sozialen Organisation
der Menschen
die kulturelle Evolution ist dann
übertragbares System sehr ähnlich wie
die DNA sie hat alle Eigenschaften eines
sich entwickelnden Systems
seit wir die Landwirtschaft entdeckt
haben haben sich die Dinge geändert und
wir fingen an wie eine größere Einheit
zu handeln genau wie ein Ameisen Volk
ein termitenvolk oder ein Bienenstock
Bienen und Ameisen sind individuelle
Organismen mit unterschiedlichen
Aufgaben
sie eilen herbei um die Kolonie zu
füttern oder zu verteidigen und bilden
gemeinsam einen Superorganismus
natürlich ist der Mensch kein soziales
Insekt aber wenn Sie ein Dorf oder eine
Stadt aus der Ferne über eine Zeit
beobachten könnten sieht es aus wie ein
wachsender voneinander abhängiger
Superorganismus
eine Neuordnung der materiellen Existenz
mit weitreichenden Folgen
wir leben heute in einer Welt des
materiellen Überflusses und billiger
Energie was sonst zu der Annahme
verleitet dass dies für den Menschen
normal ist dass dies der normale Zustand
des Menschen ist
frühere Gesellschaften sogar bis ins
Mittelalter und bis fast in die Neuzeit
hinein haben ihre Wirtschaft zu 90% der
Energieerzeugung gewidmet hauptsächlich
in Form von Nahrungsmitteln das bedeutet
dass die Menschen zu 90% Energie
produzierten mit anderen Worten dass sie
einfach nur überleben mussten
unsere Leben basierten auf sonnenströmen
das Sonnenlicht traf die Erde die
Photosynthese liest die Pflanzen wachsen
der Regen und der Boden mit den
Nährstoffen ließen die Pflanzen gedeihen
die Tiere fraßen die Feldfrüchte und wie
aßen die Tiere
Energie wandelt sich von einem Zustand
in einen anderen um
unsere Körper waren das Produkt des
Sonnenlichts des jeweiligen Tages
und wir sind nur flüchtige Wesen die
erscheinen sich ein wenig bewegen und
dann wieder verschwinden
so funktioniert das System nun einmal
und wir haben die Chance am Leben zu
bleiben sich auf diesem Planeten zu
bewegen Dinge auf diesem Planeten zu tun
Dinge auf diesem Planeten zu schaffen
weil wir diesen gigantischen
Energiefluss haben der von der Sonne
kommt
das gesamte Universum ist eine riesige
Maschine zur Verteilung von
energiepotenzialen
Energie ist alles in dem Sinne dass sich
im Universum nichts bewegt ohne dass er
ein Energiepotential vorhanden ist
es ist uns auch gelungen diese bereits
sehr große Menge an Energie weiter zu
vergrößern
durch die Nutzung dessen was eingefroren
unter der Erdkruste in Form dessen
vorhanden ist was wir fossile
Brennstoffe nennen
[Musik]
fossile Sonnenlicht ist so mächtig es
ist nicht von Magie zu unterscheiden
und wir fördern dieses uralte
Sonnenlicht erst seit einer sehr kurzen
Zeit der Menschheitsgeschichte
eine chemische Zusammensetzung von 50%
des Proteins in unserem Körper und 80%
des Stickstoffs in unserem Körper kommt
indirekt von der chemischen Signatur des
fossilen Sonnenlichts dass wir abbauen
wir sind also anders als unsere
Vorfahren sie waren aus Sonnenlicht
gemacht und wir aus fossilen
Brennstoffen in Jäger und
sammlergesellschaften kann die
Solarenergie genug Nahrung liefern um
vielleicht eine Person pro Quadratmeile
zu ernähren
die einfache Subsistenz Landwirtschaft
kann mehr Menschen ernähren aber bei
weitem nicht die Bevölkerungsdichte die
wir heute haben die Art wie wir leben
ist eine Anomalie
es gibt also für niemanden eine
Möglichkeit auf einer intuitiven Ebene
zu erkennen dass es irgendwelche
Probleme mit dem System gibt und wenn
man sich umschaut funktioniert alles
wir wissen dass wir historisch gesehen
ich meine so weit wir überhaupt darauf
achten früher Holz verwendet haben wir
sind uns irgendwie bewusst dass unsere
Vorgänger Holz verwendet haben und sie
verbrauchten so viel davon dass sie auf
etwas anderes umsteigen mussten sie
stiegen auf Kohle um und dann sind sie
auf Öl umgestiegen vor 80 Jahren befand
sich das Öl in Amerika knapp unter der
Oberfläche wir brauchten nur sehr wenige
Maschinen um die Bohrungen durchzuführen
und konnten mehr als das Hundertfache
der Energie herausholen die wir
eingesetzt haben
[Musik]
plötzlich eröffnete sich eine völlig
neue Welt des Verkehrs und damit auch
ein völlig neues Modell für die Art und
Weise wie wir uns ernähren wie wir uns
leiden wie wir uns ein Dach über dem
Kopf bauen und es hat unsere Lebensweise
völlig verändert
das hat es uns ermöglicht vom Land
wegzuziehen
während der gesamten
Menschheitsgeschichte mussten wir
verstreut leben um keine bestimmte
Ressource zu sehr zu beanspruchen
als wir begannen Lebensmittel oder
Energie zu importieren konnten wir so
gut wie überall leben wo wir wollten und
wo wir leben wollten war in den Städten
so kam es zu dieser massiven Abwanderung
und wir verließen das Land
wir alle ziehen in die Stadt weil wir
auf dem Land Lebensmittel anbauen die
wir einfach in die Stadt transportieren
können und sobald man in der Stadt ist
kann man all die anderen Dinge tun du
kannst all dieses Wissen schaffen du
kannst Technologien erschaffen je länger
man so lebt desto schwieriger wird es
sich daran zurück zu erinnern was die
Entwicklung überhaupt erst möglich
gemacht hat das war die Idee der
billigen Energie
der Mensch wurde allmählich zu einem
funktionalen Superorganismus
zunächst maximierten wir den
getreideüberschuss wir bauten mehr
Getreide an und lagerte es und das
ermöglichte es uns unsere Bevölkerung zu
vergrößern und unser Gebiet zu erweitern
aber jetzt maximieren wir den Mehrwert
wir maximieren die finanziellen
digitalen elektronischen Darstellungen
von Überschüssen
aber alles was Geld wirklich ist ist ein
Anspruch auf einige
Energiedienstleistungen
und so kommt es dass Geld
Handel Technologie alle im Dienste der
Superorganismus stehen
es ist für den Einzelnen fast unmöglich
in der modernen Gesellschaft unabhängig
zu sein
wir tragen zu einem wachsenden
Superorganismus bei und verlassen uns
darauf dass er uns ernährt und kleidet
unsere hochentwickelte Kommunikation
antreibt und sogar unsere Gesellschaften
voreinander schützt durch hoch
organisierte Kriegsführung
wir leben in einem Geflecht Energie
fressen dagegenseitiger Abhängigkeit und
wir sehen nie wirklich das große Ganze
ein Zustand des Überflusses kann
unbeabsichtigter Folgen haben
es ist das Paradoxon unserer Zeit
[Musik]
im Hintergrund von allem was wir tun ob
wir uns nun als kapitalistisch oder
sowjetisch betrachten oder vordal alles
ist eine Art Programm eine Art Rezept
eine Art Algorithmus
das logistische Funktionieren der
neolitischen Gesellschaft die überall
auf der Welt entstand
das Problem ist nur dass beim Waschen
spülen und wiederholen irgendwann wenn
man es oft genug macht die
Schwachstellen zum Vorschein kommen wenn
ich zum Beispiel mein Auto anlasse ist
das für die globale Erwärmung
statistisch gesehen bedeutungslos erst
Milliarden und aber Milliarden von
autozündungen ergeben einen Sinn und das
ist das Paradoxe ganz plötzlich erkennen
wir dass wir Teil eines Superorganismus
sind wir sind in Produktionssysteme
verstrickt Systeme der Herstellung
Systeme der Nutzung
[Musik]
es ist unglaublich wichtig zu erkennen
dass wir alle Teil des Systems sind
als soziale Organismen sind wir so etwas
wie Ameisen unsere Signale die wir
austauschen sind viel komplizierter als
die einfachen chemischen Signale die
Ameisen austauschen aber wir tauschen
Signale aus und als Menschen unternehmen
wir individuelle Handlungen die im
Großen und Ganzen immer gentes Verhalten
verursachen das Problem dass ich heute
stellt ist dass das entstehende
Verhalten sehr komplex und schädlich für
den Planeten und für uns selbst ist und
für viele andere Arten
immer gentes Verhalten ist überall um
uns herum und es kann schnelllebig und
unvorhersehbar sein
niemand kann unsere Interaktionsmuster
vorhersehen die beispielsweise zum
Internet führen zum Smartphone und zum
Verschwinden der Telefonzellen zum
Aufkommen von Serverfarm
wer weiß was als nächstes passiert
wir sitzen alle im selben Boot wenn du
den Stecker ziehst und wirklich überall
zu Fuß hingehst dann hast du vielleicht
das Recht darauf deinen Heiligenschein
zu polieren wir sind winzig kleine
Mikroben auf der Oberfläche dieses
riesigen Planeten wir können den
Planeten tatsächlich beeinflussen und
ihn zu einer Reaktion veranlassen
[Musik]
wenn wir nicht aufhören Kohlendioxid in
diesem Umfang auszustoßen werden wir in
Schwierigkeiten kommen
wir werden eine massive klimatische
Störung erleben die regengürtel werden
sich verschieben
Menschen in dreistelliger Millionenhöhe
vielleicht anderthalb Milliarden
Menschen werden Probleme haben Zugang zu
frischem Wasser und Nahrung zu bekommen
es geht nicht darum wie die Welt
aussieht wenn es kalt ist oder wenn es
warm ist wir befinden uns in einer Zeit
des Wandels interessant ist wie sich die
Welt verändert wenn die Konzentration
von Kohlendioxid und anderen
Treibhausgasen in der Atmosphäre
drastisch ansteigt wie in unserem Fall
oder wenn die Artenvielfalt durch unser
eigenes Verhalten in großen Umfang
verloren geht
was tun wir wenn eine große Veränderung
bevorsteht und wir wissen wollen was sie
in der Zukunft bewirken könnte wir
schauen uns an was in der Vergangenheit
passiert ist die geologische Geschichte
bestätigt weitgehend die Erkenntnisse
aus den Klimamodellen wenn sie sagen
dass die Verdoppelung des Kohlendioxid
zu einer Werbung von etwa zweieinhalb
bis drei Grad führen wird stimmt die
Geschichte der Erde damit weitgehend
überein ein großer Teil meiner eigenen
Forschung konzentriert sich daher auf
die Rekonstruktion des Vergangenen
Klimas
wir schauen uns dramatische
Veränderungen an und davon gibt es nicht
viele denn in der Erdgeschichte ändern
sich Dinge allmählich vor drei Jahren
habe ich mit meinem Projekt begonnen es
ging darum eine Ereignisse untersuchen
das vor etwa 120 Millionen Jahren
stattfand und genau das sollte erforscht
werden es war das was wir allgemein als
eine rasche Versauerung der Ozeane eine
rasche Erwärmung bezeichnen und wir
dachten wir schauen uns das mal an und
sehen was passiert
und als wir es mehr und mehr
untersuchten und die altersmodelle immer
besser wurden bekamen wir auch immer
bessere Rekonstruktionen des
Klimawandels und es wurde deutlich dass
dieses besondere Ereignis vor etwa 100
Millionen Jahren stattfand der
Klimawandel voll zog sich über einen
Zeitraum von etwa 40.000 Jahren das ist
derselbe Grad an Klimawandel den wir in
den nächsten 100 Jahren für möglich
halten
es ist viel mehr Energie im System
wir wissen nur sehr wenig darüber wie
die biologischen Lebenserhaltungssysteme
der Erde auf dramatische und schnelle
Veränderung reagieren werden
[Musik]
wir haben außergewöhnliche Biome auf
unserem Planeten die alle Einzelteile
eines Puzzles sind
das Bild ist klar wenn Sie alle
funktionieren und alle vorhanden sind
aber fangen sie an einzelne Teile
herauszunehmen kann man nicht mehr
wirklich sehen wie das ganze Bild
aussieht die Funktionalität des gesamten
Systems gerät aus den Fugen
[Musik]
die arktische Eiskappe schrumpft die
grönländische Eismasse geht mit 300
Gigatonnen pro Jahr verloren das sind
300 Kubikkilometer Eis pro Jahr die
Verschwinden der Ozean verändert sich
der Meeresspiegel steigt wir sehen einen
erheblichen Anstieg des Meeresspiegels
wir erwarten ein paar Meter vielleicht
mehr noch vor dem Ende des Jahrhunderts
all das sind also Tatsachen
es ist nicht so sehr die Veränderung
selbst sondern die Geschwindigkeit mit
der sie sich vollzieht je schneller der
Wandel kommt desto weniger Zeit haben
wir uns anzupassen je schneller der
Wandel Eintritt desto weniger Zeit haben
die Bäume oder das Plankton im Ozean
sich anzupassen
je schneller der Wandel kommt desto
weniger Zeit haben die Ökosysteme sich
anzupassen
und je komplexer diese sind desto
schwieriger ist es die Folgen dieses
Wandels vorherzusagen
der Klimawandel wird eine enorme
Belastung für Gesellschaften darstellen
die bereits unter innenpolitischen Druck
stehen und durch Ressourcenmangel
verursachte und Stress
zum Beispiel die Verfügbarkeit von
Nahrung und Wasser dramatische
Ereignisse im Zusammenhang mit dem
Klimawandel die alle potentiell die
Spaltung der Gesellschaft verschärfen
werden
der Zugang zu Reichtum schafft
Spaltungen der Zugang zu Nahrung und
Wasser prägt die Spaltung deutlich aus
es wird sich auf die Art und Weise
auswirken wie die Menschen auf dem
Planeten leben und wenn das Auswirkungen
hat dann bewegen sich die Menschen dann
sind sie wütend lernt wird weniger
wertvoll oder mehr wertvoll die
Bevölkerung verschieben sich und diese
Verschiebungen die stabilisieren die
Regierungen
[Musik]
wir könnten nachts aufschauen und die
weit entfernten Sterne bestaunen als
befinden wir uns in einer unberührten
Kristallen in Schneekugel
aber unsere Probleme lassen sich nicht
länger in den Hinterhof der weniger
mächtigen der weniger glücklichen unter
uns abschieben
nein hier sind wir und hier bleiben wir
wo alles von Bauern Hunden LED-Leuchten
Blumen Bleistiften Politikern
Mikrowellen und Pinguinen Vergangenheit
Gegenwart und Zukunft miteinander
verknüpft ist
in den nächsten zehn Jahren werden wir
unseren Wohlstand um 50% steigern
die tiefgründige Frage lautet bedeutet
das dass wir tatsächlich um 50% reicher
sein werden
50% besser dran 50% glücklicher
um ein paar mehr Fakten zu nennen über
den Klimawandel die Verknappung des
Erdöls oder die Zerstörung der Umwelt
die Menschen wissen nicht was sie tun
sollen weil sie Teil dieses Organismus
sind der versucht mehr wohlfühl
Chemikalien im Gehirn zu erhalten
das Laufband wird immer kürzer und
kürzer und kürzer und die Zahl der
Menschen die auf dem Laufband sein
wollen wird immer größer und größer und
größer und irgendwann wird es keinen
Platz mehr zum Laufen geben und dann
werden die Leute Herunterfallen viele
Menschen werden herunterfallen
wir sind zutiefst davon motiviert einen
Sinn im Leben zu haben wir sind
motiviert weil wir ein Gefühl der
Autonomie Effektivität und Kontrolle
haben
wenn wir den Eindruck haben dass unsere
gaben unsere Energie unsere Lebenskraft
keinen wirklichen Einfluss haben dann
leiden wir diese Energie sehr
wahrscheinlich um und zwar dorthin wo
wir das Gefühl haben dass wir damit am
meisten bewirken können und wo ist das
in unserer Kultur im Moment im Konsum
der Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
Theorie gesprochen in der alle Dinge im
Guten und oft auch im schlechten
miteinander verbunden sind da wir hier
im stärksten industrialisierten Teil der
industrialisierten Welt Leben reichen
unsere Tentakel überall hin
[Musik]
Wirksamkeit ist die Fähigkeit ein
gewünschtes Ergebnis zu erzielen aber
sind die Ergebnisse die wir erzielen
auch die die wir beabsichtigen
wilde Tiere verschwinden für immer
unsere Intelligenz gestaltet die Welt
vor unseren Augen neu
heute können wir einfach auf einen Link
klicken und etwas vor unserer Haustür
vorfinden ohne eine Ahnung davon zu
haben wie es dorthin gelangt ist
alles was wir über die Gründe wissen ist
der Preis wir werden mehr und mehr von
den tatsächlichen Kosten der Herstellung
und des Transports dessen was wir
verwenden losgelöst
[Musik]
Energie steht im Mittelpunkt der Physik
aber für den Laien ist es wahrscheinlich
am einfachsten zu erklären dass Energie
die Fähigkeit ist dabei zu verrichten
Arbeit ist Kraft durch Entfernung
jedes Mal wenn Sie also etwas von China
in die USA transportieren oder vom Boden
zur Decke das kostet Energie wenn man
zur Arbeit fährt braucht man natürlich
auch Energie um einen Liter Wasser zum
Kochen zu bringen benötigt man das
Äquivalent von 500 Kalorien aus Nahrung
jeder Art von Umwandlung erfordert
Energie wir sind mächtige Lebewesen auf
diesem Planeten aber wir brauchen es
Ökosystem zum Überleben also wollen wir
es nicht zerstören
denn das wäre ziemlich schlecht und dies
ist ein Übergang man kann es auch eine
Revolution nennen sie können es nennen
wie Sie wollen der Punkt ist dass es
solche Revolutionen gegeben hat solche
Übergänge in der Vergangenheit aber
diese Übergänge haben ihren Preis
eine Energiewende muss mit Energie
bezahlt werden
Energie ist die Währung des Lebens
Energie schafft Bewegung und Nahrung
alles Leben zapft Energieflüsse an
früher haben wir Energie in
Pferdestärken gemessen
ein Pferd konnte die Arbeit von zehn
Männern erledigen
erledigen
man brauchte 450 Pferde oder mehr um die
gleiche Arbeit zu erledigen wie ein
einziger Sattelschlepper
und im Gegensatz zu Pferden können LKW
Tag und Nacht und bei jedem Wetter
arbeiten
der Fluss der fossilen Brennstoffe hat
unsere Gesellschaft den Schwung gebracht
um es abzukürzen wir haben jetzt die
Wissenschaft zu erkennen dass diese
fossilen Sklaven sich nicht beschweren
nicht schlafen unermüdlich sind super
stark aber sie defizieren und atmen und
ihr Atem verursacht die Erwärmung
unserer Biosphäre und unsere Ozeane
versauern wir sollten Sie im Boden
belassen doch ganz so einfach ist es
nicht
betrachtet man die Energie die in
fossilen Brennstoffen steckt werden 90%
der Arbeit in der menschlichen
Wirtschaft durch fossile Sklaven
geleistet
der durchschnittliche Amerikaner
verbraucht 220.000 Kilokalorien jeden
Tag daran denken wir nicht wir denken
nur an die 3000 oder dreieinhalb tausend
Kilokalorien aus Lebensmitteln die wir
essen
aber unser energie-fußabdruck ist fast
100 mal so groß wenn man unsere Busse
und Flugzeuge berücksichtigt und alle
Krankenhäuser disneylands und nascars
und all die verschiedenen Dinge die wir
kaufen die aus der ganzen Welt
importiert werden
darin investieren die Menschen und viele
Rentenfonds und viele der Institutionen
von denen die Menschheit abhängt
tendieren natürlich zum Öl
erneuerbare Energien sind zwar
ausgereift und werden immer billiger
aber sie werden diese Infrastruktur
nicht ersetzen können und diese
Zivilisation
wir haben nur eine sehr begrenzte Zeit
für den Übergang zu einer
kohlenstoffarmen Wirtschaft aber es ist
sehr naiv einfach zu sagen lassen wir es
im Boden und halten alles andere am
laufen wenn Sie also fragen kann
Solarenergie unsere Gesellschaft
antreiben so wie sie heute ist dann
haben sie bereits die Antwort sie lautet
nein das ist nicht möglich
wenn sie von Öl Gas und Kohle auf
Solarenergie umsteigen wollen dann
müssen eine Menge Dinge verändert werden
unser derzeitiges lebensmittelsystem ist
eine energiesenke wir verbrauchen zehn
bis zwölfossile Kalorien um eine
nahrungskalorie zu erzeugen derzeit gibt
es auf der Erde Maschinen im Wert von
etwa 100 Millionen Dollar die mit Benzin
oder Dieselkraftstoff betrieben werden
für ein Barrel Öl für das wir 50 Dollar
bezahlen stehen also tausende fossiler
Sklaven hinter uns
der amerikanische Fahrzeugbestand
umfasst 250 bis 270 Millionen Autos und
leichte Nutzfahrzeuge
wir sprechen von mehr als einem
Jahrzehnte Produktion und wir sprechen
von mehr Wohlstand als das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt in einem Jahr um es
zu ersetzen
wir werden diese Veränderung also nicht
über Nacht erreichen sie sehen es gibt
einen Parameter der für die Bewertung
dieser Art von Dingen sehr grundlegend
ist den nennt man energienrendite auf
investierte Energie
kostet keine Dollars ich meine ja aber
es kostet wirklich Energie Öl ist die
größte Industrie auf dem Planeten es
gibt also den Takt vor was die Inflation
angeht wenn Sie also den Ölpreis erhöhen
steigen alle anderen Preise bis die
Menschen sich angepasst haben und sich
die Förderkosten noch leisten können für
Öl
das ist also nicht so dass uns das Öl
ausgeht oder Kohle oder Gas sondern dass
es immer teurer wird sie zu beschaffen
was die Energie betrifft weil es teurer
ist hat es weniger Vorteile für den Rest
der Gesellschaft die 1930er Jahre als
das Beverly Hill unter der Erde Brote
das haben wir alles aufgebraucht
die nettoenergie das heißt die Energie
die übrig bleibt nachdem wir die
Energiekosten für die Suche und
Gewinnung der Energie bezahlt haben ist
derzeit rückläufig
wir sind uns des Ausmaßes und der
Bedeutung dessen was geschieht nicht
bewusst
wenn wir Schulden aufnehmen versprechen
wir sie mit zukünftiger Energie
zurückzuzahlen
die fossilen Brennstoffe werden nicht
ewig reichen sie können nicht ewig
reichen das Energiepotenzial in einem
Barrel Öl entspricht einem Menschen der
viereinhalb Jahre lang 40 Stunden pro
Woche arbeitet
man muss an die Zukunft denken man muss
etwas für die Zukunft sparen um eine
Ernte eine erneuerbare Energie zu
erhalten ein altes Sprichwort besagt
dass man sein Saatgut nicht essen sollte
kluge Landwirte wissen dass wenn sie ihr
Saatgut aufessen nichts mehr übrig
bleibt was Sie für eine zukünftige Ernte
anpflanzen könnten werden künftige
Generationen auf die heutige Zeit
zurückblicken und einen Großteil der
Energie die wir verbrauchen als
Verschwendung betrachten essen wir
unseren Saat Mais
viele von uns sind dazu übergegangen ein
Maß an Komfort und Bequemlichkeit zu
erwarten wie es das in unserer
biologischen Vergangenheit noch nie
gegeben hat
[Musik]
wir müssen unsere Erwartungen neu
definieren nicht als das was wir
verlieren werden sondern als das was wir
gewinnen könnten wenn wir uns auf etwas
anderes vorbereiten
fossile Brennstoffe sind schlecht wir
müssen sie im Boden belassen also haben
wir diese große
destinvestitionskampagne bei der wir
aufhören in Kohle Öl und Erdgas zu
investieren aber wenn wir aufhören in
die Aktien zu investieren solange wir
weiterhin fliegen und fahren und die
Infrastruktur auf billige Verkehrsmittel
ausgerichtet ist und auf die globale
Vernetzung der Lieferketten dann wird
irgendein Hedgefond diese Aktien einfach
15 billiger zurückkaufen
wenn wir zum Beispiel über Öl nachdenken
können wir sehr leicht in den Modus der
abhängigkeitsrede geraten ich werde
diese Flasche Whisky im Schrank stehen
lassen und keinen Tropfen davon anrühren
was paradoxerweise bedeutet dass ich
immer noch auf diesen Whisky fixiert bin
das ist natürlich kein wirkliches
umdenken
der Mythos das die Dinge reibungslos
funktionieren sollten um das ein
reibungsloses Funktionieren etwas Reales
ist hat sich ein wenig verfestigt
[Musik]
wenn sie sich in 10 oder 20 Jahren
wiederfinden in einer Welt in der
Energie nicht billig ist müssen Sie
dieses riesige globale Städtesystem
irgendwie rückgängig machen wenn man in
der Geschichte zurückblickt kann man
feststellen dass so etwas schon einmal
passiert ist ein Grund für den Untergang
des Römischen Reichs war dass es nicht
mehr in der Lage war Rom und die anderen
großen Stadtstaaten weiterhin mit
Lebensmitteln und anderen Gütern zu
versorgen und die Städte waren nicht
mehr bewohnbar sie funktioniert einfach
nicht mehr
was passiert also dieses Mal
in der Vergangenheit waren es Konflikte
mit anderen Stämmen die den menschlichen
Fortschritt so wie er ist hervorgebracht
haben zu einem ungeheuren Preis von
Blutvergießen
der Erste Weltkrieg brachte das Radio
und die Flugzeuge hervor der Zweite
Weltkrieg brachte uns die Kernenergie
der weltraumwettlauf zwischen den
Vereinigten Staaten und der Sowjetunion
und der kalte Krieg bescherten uns
Kommunikationssatelliten globale
Positionsbestimmungen und vieles andere
und jetzt sind wir in einer Situation in
der wir zusammenarbeiten müssen wir
können nicht gegeneinander arbeiten wir
müssen zusammenarbeiten wir müssen mit
Blick auf die Zukunft zusammenarbeiten
nicht gegeneinander in der Gegenwart
das Problem liegt nicht so sehr darin
was wir über die Welt in der wir leben
denken sondern darin wie wir über die
Welt in der wir leben denken
nun hier haben wir ein menschliches
Gehirn wenn man es in echt sieht wirkt
es ein bisschen enttäuschend nicht wahr
es ist sehr klein für das was es tut
wenn man bedenkt wozu wir fähig sind und
dass das alles aus so einem kleinen
Objekt kommt es ist ziemlich
bemerkenswert
nehmen wir uns einen Moment Zeit um uns
in eine theoretische Welt zu versetzen
in der alles was existiert in allen
Maßstäben den gleichen Wert hat
von Wolkenkratzern und Bäumen bis hin zu
Menschen Cola und Tassen und Orang-Utans
Schuhen und Koffern Schiffen Wasser
Diamanten und Libellen
sogar die Zeit selbst
wenn wir uns vorstellen können dass alle
Dinge gleich sind dann wissen wir dass
das was wir als Realität wahrnehmen von
den Werturteilen kommt die in unseren
Köpfen existieren
[Musik]
wenn alles auf die gleiche Weise
existiert dann haben wir einen
interessantes Problem wenn es wahr ist
dass ich allein durch meine Existenz
eine große Anzahl von Lebensformen töte
dann muss ich mir überlegen welche Arten
von Lebewesen ich töten möchte und ich
muss das ganz bewusst und ausdrücklich
tun und bewusst und explizit über Dinge
zu sprechen ist eine unglaubliche
Belastung
es gibt immer eine unbeabsichtigte Folge
dessen was man tut
die Realität spielt sich auf
verschiedenen Ebenen ab und zwar
gleichzeitig man kann es nie ganz
richtig machen wir sind also wieder mit
dem Gedanken konfrontiert verschiedene
Schattierungen von Heuchelei zu
erforschen
sie kennen die berühmte Studie wenn ich
Ihnen jetzt 20 Dollar anbiete kann ich
Ihnen in einer Woche auf 50 Dollar geben
die Menschen sind fast schon gezwungen
sich für das kurzfristige zu entscheiden
kurzfristig zu handeln ja wenn man
darüber nachdenkt ist das bis zu einem
gewissen Punkt sehr vernünftig weil du
tot sein könntest der Spatz in der Hand
ist also mehr wert als die Taube auf dem
Dach also gibt es eine gewisse
Rationalität zu dieser Diskontierung
Organismen die sich Sorgen um 50 Jahre
in der Zukunft machten wurden von
Organismen verdrängt die sich und die
nächsten 5 Minuten Sorgen machten
unser Schicksal liegt in unserer eigenen
Hand
von niemandem sonst
wie werden wir die Zukunft gestalten um
ein besseres Ergebnis zu erzielen
was macht unsere Identität aus
[Musik]
sind wir unsere Triebe
sind wir unsere Prinzipien
wer sind wir
ich bin ist in Wirklichkeit die
Ansammlung meiner Erfahrungen mit
anderen Menschen meine Interaktionen mit
anderen Menschen Babys haben kein
Selbstkonzept haben keine Vorstellung
davon wer sie sind aber wenn sie mit
anderen Menschen interagieren beginnen
Sie sich ein Bild von sich selbst zu
machen ein Gefühl dafür zu entwickeln
wer Sie sind und sich Gedanken darüber
zu machen wer Sie sind
das ist wirklich von den Ansichten und
Antworten anderer Leute übernommen
worden
[Musik]
in unserer modernen Gesellschaft
verbringen die Menschen viel Zeit und
Mühe damit Gegenstände und Besitztümer
anzuhäufen und manchmal haben diese
Dinge keinen besonderen Nutzen ganz und
gar nicht aber es ist fast so als
müssten wir uns die Dinge um uns herum
aneignen um eine Aussage darüber zu
machen wer wir sind wir benutzen Objekte
als eine Erweiterung unserer selbst im
Leben der fühlenden Wesen ist das
Verlangen unvermeidlich die
Plastikprodukte die der Konsum aus dem
Begehren gemacht hat sind vielleicht
optional aber das Begehren ist
unvermeidlich
der gleiche Antrieb ist es der das Apple
leicht macht und jedes Jahr neues iPhone
zu verkaufen ich meine ich garantiere
Ihnen dass Sie das nächste iPhone nicht
brauchen man weiß noch nicht einmal
welche neuen Funktionen es geben wird
und man wird es auch nicht wissen bis
man es sieht aber sie sind sich ziemlich
sicher dass sie ihn gefallen werden wenn
sie sie sehen und genau das war der Sinn
dieser Idee der dynamischen Obsoleszenz
es ist erlaubt zu fühlen ein bestimmten
emotionalen Zustand zu erreichen für
eine kurze Zeit und dann fast so schnell
wie man ihn erreicht hat verblaster
wieder und man muss etwas anderes nehmen
wir lieben die Möglichkeit uns schneller
so zu fühlen wie wir uns fühlen wollen
[Musik]
wir mögen heute ein sehr entwickeltes
Bewusstsein haben Arbeit viel Wissen
kulturellen Wissen technischem Wissen
aber die Art und Weise wie wir denken
ist immer noch sehr stark von einem
primitiven unbewussten beeinflusst dass
wir entwickelt haben vor Millionen von
Jahren
[Musik]
wir Menschen sind nicht nur wie Tiere
wir sind Tiere und als Tiere
konkurrieren wir um Partner
Organismen in freier Wildbahn die über
zusätzliche Ressourcen verfügen die
auffällige Schwänze oder große Geweihe
zur Schau stellen können sagen ihren
Partner damit dass meine Gene so gut
sind dass ich damit nicht hinterm Berg
halten muss weil ich so stark bin ich
habe tolle Eigenschaften
das gleiche Phänomen tritt in
menschlichen gesellschaftlichen auf um
Mitglieder des anderen Geschlechts zu
beeindrucken
viele dieser Darstellungen erfordern
zusätzliche Energie und natürliche
Ressourcen die wir nicht wirklich dazu
brauchen um genetisch zusammenzupassen
aber wie reagieren auf diese kulturellen
Signale als ob diese Dinge wirklich
wichtig wären
ich glaube dass die Frage des Status und
des Zeigens unsere Status einer der
wichtigsten Faktoren unseres Verhaltens
ist
wissen sie wer das am besten weiß das
sind die Marketing und Werbefachleute
denn wenn sie uns Designersachen
verkaufen oder wenn Sie sich mit dem
beschäftigen was andere Leute denken
dann Zapfen sie das an weil sie intuitiv
verstehen dass wir alle Tiere sind die
einen bestimmten sozialen Status
anstreben
[Musik]
wir mögen es praktisch wir mögen es wenn
etwas neu ist und wir mögen Taschen auf
denen Namen stehen wir trinken gerne aus
Flaschen die wir wegwerfen können wir
mögen Styroporbehälter für unser Fast
Food
Kunststoff selbst ist etwas das im Laufe
der Zeit bestehen bleibt es wird
recycelt es wird recycelt das wird
kleiner es wird kleiner und jetzt ist es
direkt wieder in unserem Blutkreislauf
nachweisbar
[Musik]
wir sind nicht im Einklang mit dem was
wir hören und verstehen und dem was wir
wissen was vor sich geht und dem Leben
dass ich führe
einschließlich all der Dinge die ich
liebe und die ökologisch wirklich
problematisch sein könnten aber die ich
trotzdem liebe wir haben also diese
äußerst positive Einstellung zu uns
selbst und für versuchen diese
Charakterisierung insofern beizubehalten
als wir uns nur mit Informationen
befassen die uns in dieser
Voreingenommenheit bestätigen
wir werden Dinge die wir getan haben
absichtlich umgestalten um die Kohärenz
dessen was wir sind zu bewahren
[Musik]
unsere Gehirne erzeugen ständig diese
Verzerrungen wir haben keinen direkten
Kontakt zu Realität
eine der überlebenswichtigen
Eigenschaften die wir entwickelt haben
war die Gruppen Identität
und auch heute noch spielt die
Gruppenidentität eine wichtige Rolle in
unserem Leben und hat eine bedeutende
unbewusste Wirkung auf unsere
Einstellungen und unser Handeln wir
haben also die Tendenz die Schuld immer
anderen zuzuschieben anstatt sie selbst
zu akzeptieren und das ist Teil der
Voreingenommenheit die die Kohärenz
dieses Daseins als guter Mensch schafft
oder bewahrt
[Musik]
wir sind also alle in der Lage mit einer
falschen Vorstellung davon herumzulaufen
was in unserer Welt wirklich vor sich
geht und es gibt keinen Mechanismus und
keine Stimme in uns die uns signalisiert
dass das künstlich ist
wir wollen nicht in einem Zustand der
Angst leben wir wollen glauben dass die
Dinge die wir gerne tun sich nie ändern
werden
verwechseln wir das was wir brauchen mit
dem was wir wünschen und das was wir
wünschen mit dem was wir brauchen
das Verlangen geht den Bedürfnis logisch
voraus und das Bedürfnis ist in
Wirklichkeit nur ein stabilisiertes
verlangen dass wahrscheinlich
gesellschaftlich in etwas scheinbar
notwendiges verwandelt worden ist ich
denke also wir müssen ein wenig
vorsichtig sein wenn wir davon sprechen
dass wir in einer ökologischen
Gesellschaft leben in der unsere
Bedürfnisse mit unseren Wünschen
übereinstimmen
es gibt also diesen ständigen Tanz
zwischen den hemmungszentren die wissen
was gut für uns ist im oberen Teil des
Gehirns insbesondere im präfrontalen
Bereich und in den Bereichen des
Mittelhirns die für emotionale Impulse
zuständig sind die einfach nur diese
leckere Sache greifen will und zwar
sofort
sagen wir wir sind in einer Bäckerei und
alles sieht so gut aus und unser Gehirn
das im Laufe der Evolution auf das
Verlangen nach Fett und Zucker
ausgerichtet wurde spielt verrückt es
will einfach nur eines von diesen
leckeren Dingern aber dann sagt uns
unser präfrontaler Cortex der Teil des
Gehirns der lernt der versteht das macht
dick du hast ein blutzuckerproblem das
ist nicht so gut für dich
[Musik]
und der präfrontale Cortex hat die
Fähigkeit emotionale Impulse zu hemmen
und wenn wir die wahren Kosten der Dinge
die wir benutzen verstehen und das was
wir der Umwelt antun gilt derselbe
Mechanismus
wir können uns auf den Balkon des
Geistes zurückziehen von wo aus wir
alles sehen was vor sich geht dann
können wir eine bessere Entscheidung
treffen das ist der erste Schritt zu
Änderung unserer Gewohnheiten denn ohne
Achtsamkeit bemerken wir die
Entscheidungspunkte nicht einmal wir tun
einfach blind spontan automatisch das
was wir tun wenn wir so weitermachen wie
bisher werden wir von unseren alten
Gewohnheiten beherrscht
wenn es Unsicherheit gibt wenn ein
Gefühl der Unsicherheit der
Verwundbarkeit und der Verwirrung
herrscht
genau dann sind wir natürlich am
anfälligsten dafür uns an eine Botschaft
eine Stimme eine Person zu halten die
auftaucht und in der Lage ist diesen
Ängsten und diesen Ungewissheiten mit
seiner solchen Zuversicht und Gewissheit
zu begegnen und das ist es was wir in
der Politik immer und immer wieder
erleben
[Musik]
ich brauche wohl nicht die
offensichtlichen Beispiele dafür zu
nennen was passiert wenn das Gefühl der
Angst von der breiten Öffentlichkeit
aufgenommen wird
ungefähr die Hälfte des Reichtums im
Land wird vom obersten 1% der
Bevölkerung gehalten doch es gibt viele
von uns und meine Eltern gehörten
sicherlich auch dazu die von einem Tag
auf den anderen um es Überleben kämpften
und sie sahen zu ihren Lebzeiten in den
30er Jahren tatsächlich wie Menschen
verhungerten weil sie ihren
Lebensunterhalt nicht verdienen konnten
so haben die meisten Amerikaner das
nicht gesehen aber einige Amerikaner
empfinden das immer noch so und sie
spüren die Bedrohung und die Angst vor
Arbeitslosigkeit sie konzentrieren sich
also auf die nächste Zeit
in jeder symbiotischen Beziehung ist es
ein wenig verwirrend er oben und wer
unten ist und das kann jeden Moment
zusammenbrechen
[Musik]
dem Wunsch gerettet zu werden liegt ein
tiefes Gefühl der Ohnmacht zugrunde
[Musik]
Schlag die Zeitung auf oder sie dir eine
herkömmliche ökologische Dokumentation
an und was du sehen willst sind alle
möglichen Fakten die dazu dienen dass
man sich verängstigt verärgert und
schuldig fühlt so reden wir mit uns
selbst über ökologische Katastrophen das
Problem ist nur das für uns
psychologisch gesehen immer noch in die
Zeit zurückversetzen bevor etwas
passiert so dass wir gefühlt die Wahl
haben ob wir diesen Weg gehen wollen
oder nicht der Punkt ist dass wir den
Weg bereits eingeschlagen haben
wenn wir auf der Seite der
Klimawissenschaftler über die Realität
des Klimawandels sprechen klingt das auf
den ersten Blick wie ein kleiner
Wermutstropfen es ist also eine
natürliche Reaktion wenn man schlechte
Nachrichten hört und jemand anderes sagt
nein nein das ist nicht wahr zumindest
so hoffen dass derjenige der sagt dass
dies nicht passieren wird recht hat
sechs Jahre lang habe ich im Kongress
gesagt dass der Klimawandel Unsinn ist
ich habe wirklich nichts davon
verstanden
da ich den wahrscheinlich rötlichen
Bezirk im rötesten Bundesstaat der
nationalt wusste ich dass ich dagegen
sein musste
und mein Sohn kam zu mir er wählte zum
ersten Mal er war gerade 18 geworden und
er sagte zu mir Papa ich werde für dich
stimmen
aber du wirst dich um die Umwelt kümmern
ihr Kind ist krank
98 Ärzte sagen behandeln sie ihn so
zwei Ärzte sagen nein der andere ist der
richtige Weg und sie sagen ich folge den
zweien man sie gehen ein großes Risiko
für die Kinder ein
einige Leute meinen dass wir ein
Informationsdefizit haben wenn wir den
Menschen nur mehr wissenschaftliche
Informationen geben würden wenn wir
Ihnen die Wissenschaft zeigen würden
dann würden Sie zustimmen
wir haben Leute die ihren Lebens
Unterhalt und viel Geld damit verdienen
im Talk Radio und dem Talk TV alles
mögliche auszusprechen
sie haben letzte Nacht im Holiday Inn
Express übernachtet und sind jetzt
Klimaexperten
es ist ein identifikationsproblem es
sieht nicht aus wie mein Stammes klingt
nicht wie mein Stamm klingt nicht wie
unser Kriegsgeschrei klingt nicht für
unser Lied
zu oft wird die Klimawissenschaft so
dargestellt als sei sie eine Art neue
Religion und man muss daran glauben
nein verlangen sie von den Menschen
nicht dass sie an die Klimawissenschaft
glauben ich sage einfach hier sind ein
paar Daten nun was sagt ihnen ihre
Glaubenstradition was ich mit diesen
Daten machen soll bei mir heißt es dass
ich ein Verwalter dieser herrlichen
Schöpfung bin
manchmal stellt sich heraus dass die
Wissenschaft falsch liegt aber manchmal
stellt sich heraus dass sie sehr richtig
liegt und der Schlüssel zu
wissenschaftlichen Unternehmungen über
die wir heute sprechen wollen ist
Offenheit Zugang zu den Daten und die
vollständige Herausgabe der Daten auf
diese Weise bringen wir die Wissenschaft
voran ich freue mich auf die Anhörung
hervorsitzender ich danke ihnen es gab
immer wieder über Zivilisationen hinweg
große Umwälzungen in unserem Denken über
tausende von Jahren dachte man dass die
Erde im Mittelpunkt des Universums steht
heute wissen wir das stimmt nicht und
dann gab es natürlich auch die
Vorstellung dass der Mensch an der
Spitze des Tierreichs steht aber jetzt
entdecken wir durch natürliche Selektion
und davinismus dass wir nur eine von
vielen Arten sind und schließlich wenn
man über das selbst nachdenkt und die
Vorstellung dass wir als Individuen die
Kontrolle überall unsere Handlungen und
Verhaltensweisen haben bemerken wir dass
das so auch nicht ganz richtig ist
ich denke also dass die Wissenschaft
gezeigt hat dass die Arroganz des
Individualismus die Egozentrik mit der
wir unseren Planeten unsere Spezies und
uns selbst betrachten ungerechtfertigt
ist
Ökologie
das Wort leitet sich vom griechischen
oikos ab was so viel wie Haushalt
bedeutet es ist das Studium der
Beziehungen die alle Mitglieder des
Haushalts der Erde miteinander verbinden
wir können nicht davon ausgehen dass die
Ökologie nur dort drüben im Jenseits
existiert denn sie hat keine Grenzen und
befindet sich in einem ständigen Wandel
die Ökologie ist intim und geht uns
direkt unter die Haut und durch sie
hindurch sie ist durchlässig und
grenzenlos und chaotisch
das Innere und das Äußere sind immer
miteinander verwoben
wenn wir also über Nachhaltigkeit
sprechen
was hoffen wir zu erhalten
ein Problem der Philosophie ist dass sie
nicht nur in ihrem Kopf stattfindet die
Philosophie ist überall alles war in
gewisser Weise ein Traum im Kopf eines
Menschen hin gebauten Raum
der Gedanke ist nicht nur etwas das hier
drin ist der Gedanke ist überall
die Geschichte in der wir derzeit leben
ist die dass wir die Wirtschaft durch
den Konsum von Waren wachsen lassen und
insbesondere dem Konsum von Gütern die
nur in begrenzten Mengen vorhanden sind
wir haben die Tendenz als sinnstiftende
Geschichten stiftende Menschen als
Lebewesen Charaktere zu haben
Protagonisten zu haben wer sind
Bösewichte und wer sind solche die
Helden und Retter sind das ist tief in
unserer menschlichen Psyche verankert
und so machen wir uns einen Reim auf die
Welt
und die Tendenz geht verständlicherweise
dahin Bösewichte zu erschaffen wie zum
Beispiel Konzerne oder die Ölindustrie
und Helden zu erschaffen die öko-krieger
das ist zwar verständlich aber was ist
tatsächlich tut es schafft eine Art
Ausnahmeregelung bei der wir Haus als
Individuen in gewisser Weise aus der
Geschichte ausklammern
in unserer Kultur wird derzeit viel
kritisiert dass der Kapitalismus
schlecht ist und dass es ohne
Kapitalismus nicht geht dass wir die
Dinge ohne Kapitalismus nicht
beeinflussen würden und das ist
teilweise wahr
[Musik]
diesem System liegt der optimale
Beutetrieb zugrunde der unserer
tierischen Natur innewohnt
Wölfe zum Beispiel
sind besser dran wenn Sie einen Elch
erlegen als wenn sie dieselbe Zeit und
Energie aufwenden eine Maus oder ein
Kaninchen zu jagen
sie sind evolutionär besser angepasst
und haben mehr Kalorien um ihre
Nachkommen aufzuziehen
die gleiche Dynamik gibt es bei Menschen
wir investieren gerne wenig und bekommen
dafür viel zurück
wir machen das an der Börse wenn wir 20%
Rabatt auf Schuhe bekommen
ein zwei für eins Cocktail zur Happy
Hour oder ein Schnäppchen beim Hauskauf
über eine Zwangsversteigerung
der Kapitalismus ist nicht nur gut oder
schlecht
der Kapitalismus steht im Dienste des
Superorganismus
gemeinsam funktionieren wir wie ein
gigantisches Wolfsrudel das nach mehr
Energie giert
[Musik]
wissen Sie eine der vielen
Kriegsursachen ist der Mangel an Energie
denn Energie fließt immer von einer Art
verdichtetem Zustand in einen weniger
verdichteten Zustand
Entropie bedeutet dass die Dinge ständig
auf Null zurückgehen
wir können keine Maschine bauen die die
Entropie umkehrt
Entropie ist der Grund warum die Zeit
nur in eine Richtung zu laufen scheint
Entropie ist der Grund warum sich ein
zerbrochenes Glas nie wieder zu einem
perfekten Glas zusammensetzt und wenn
Sie auf der Suche nach der perfekten
ökologischen Maschine sind die die
Energie tatsächlich vollständig
zurückgibt dann fürchte ich dass sie bis
nach dem Ende des Universums damit
warten müssen bis sie das was die
Maschine aus dem System herausgesaugt
hat wieder hinein bekommen
man muss also bei der Analyse von Tieren
und zwar von Tieren und weitesten Sinne
ich schließe die Menschen mit ein immer
Raum lassen beim Gedanken dass wir immer
das Richtige tun werden dass wir alle
unsere Handlungen unsere
futtersuch-strategien und alles andere
optimiert haben werden denn wenn wir
alles immer richtig gemacht hätten gäbe
es doch keine Probleme oder es gäbe
keine Armut es gebe keinen Klimawandel
es gäbe keine Kriege
wo du sitzt bestimmt wo du stehst und
wenn du sozusagen gefesselt bist wenn du
in einer bestimmten Branche arbeitest
und dort deine Zukunft siehst hältst du
natürlich daran fest
[Musik]
so etwas wie einen freien Markt gibt es
nicht ich hoffe die Menschen können das
verstehen denn wenn es freie Märkte gebe
würden sie so enden wie Ende des 19
Jahrhunderts mit einigen wenigen sehr
mächtigen Konzernen die ganz Amerika
kontrollieren
ohne die Hilfe des Staates bei der
Gestaltung der Marktkräfte werden die
Marktkräfte durch sehr kurzfristige
Anforderungen genommen die von uns an
sie gestellt werden
durch unser Bedürfnis zur Tankstelle zu
gehen und das billigste Benzin zu
bekommen durch das Bedürfnis aus der
Rentenkasse 8% Rendite zu erhalten egal
worin man investiert es ist wirklich
schwierig die sechs sieben oder acht
Prozent pro Jahr zu verdienen die in den
versicherungsmathematischen Berechnungen
vorgesehen waren als die Pensionsfonds
eingerichtet wurden es ist also nicht
irgendeine ausländische Institution die
uns dazu bringt kurzfristig zu handeln
sondern wir selbst
warum hat die Verwaltung die
Energiekrise nicht schon vor einigen
Jahren vorausgesehen und einen positiven
Aktionsplan formuliert und etwas dagegen
getan
wir müssen eine andere Perspektive
einnehmen
vor ein paar Jahren habe ich eine
Kongress Abgeordnete gefragt was ist das
schwierigste Problem mit dem sie zu tun
haben genau jetzt und sie sagte
Bundeszuschüsse für
hochwasserversicherung an der Küste
denn wir haben sie immer subventioniert
und die Kosten für die Subventionen
werden immer höher und die Menschen
bestehen darauf diese Häuser zu kaufen
die der Erosion durch die Gezeiten und
Überschwemmungen ausgesetzt sind und
letztlich der Zerstörung
es gibt keine transparente
verantwortliche Preisgestaltung für alle
Auswirkungen der Verbrennung fossiler
Brennstoffe
die Märkte funktionieren immer noch
nicht richtig und wenn diese Kosten erst
einmal aufgedeckt und auf den Tisch
gelegt werden an der Zapfsäule
ersichtlich dann werden die
verbraucherentscheidungen treffen die in
ihrem eigenen Interesse liegen
wir werden Treibstoff auf unseren
Dächern herstellen
natürlich sage ich nicht dass wir das
Nirvana erreichen und keinen Krieg mehr
haben werden eine der Ursachen für
Kriege würde wegfallen weil Energie in
größerem Umfang zur Verfügung stöhnte
und besser über die Welt verteilt wäre
wenn wir unseren Namen gerecht werden
wollen Homo sapiens was so viel wie
weiser Mensch bedeutet müssen wir unsere
Unterbewussten Motivationen unser
unterbewusstes verlangen und
Rechtfertigungen verstehen und die
wahren Kosten der Energie
wenn man sich die Vergangenheit anschaut
dann geht es um Entscheidungen wie man
in der Welt leben will die die Menschen
in der Vergangenheit getroffen haben
es mag technisch wahr sein dass wir
nicht alles darüber wissen woher unsere
Lebensmittel stammen wir reden uns immer
wieder ein dass das schwierig ist aber
lies dir einfach die Rückseite der
cornflakespackung durch und schau bei
Google nach woher alles kommt
aus welchen Ländern kommen die Rohstoffe
für ein iPhone
hey da ist es
oh ich hier wie wäre es damit die wahren
Kette
[Musik]
wir wissen das bestimmte Dinge die wir
jetzt tun bestimmte Teile unseres
Gehirns aktivieren oder zu einer
bestimmten Einstellung oder zu
bestimmten Reaktionen anregen wie auch
immer wie es nennen wollen wir könnten
an die Art von Feuer denken dass der
Konsum in uns entfacht mit all den
begierten als eine Art Tor zu weiteren
Wünschen die tatsächlich interessanter
sein könnten und mehr am Einklang mit
anderen Lebensformen
wenn man sich das Universum als einen
Energiefluss vorstellt dann ändert das
einfach die ganze Perspektive auf das
was es bedeutet am Leben zu sein
alle lebenden Systeme benötigen als
Individuen Energie wenn wir
strategischer darüber nachdenken würden
wie wir die Energie des Planeten nutzen
wäre das Leben für alle Lebewesen besser
individuell ist Verhalten kann sich auf
einer anderen Ebene anders darstellen in
einem anderen Verhältnis ist eine Art
Interaktion
wir brauchen keinen 24/7 Zugang zu
Energie
wir brauchen rund um die Uhr Zugang zu
Gefühlen wenn wir einfach aufeinander
zugehen können ohne diese Herablassung
die viel zu oft auftritt wenn wir uns
mit Umweltthemen befassen und sagen also
gut suchen wir nach etwas das
funktioniert einer der wichtigsten
Aspekte der Evolution der Zusammenarbeit
ist die Entwicklung komplexer
moralischer Gefühle wie Sympathie
Einfühlungsvermögen Mitgefühl das sind
die Schlüsselbegriffe ich denke das ist
entscheidend für unser Verständnis der
menschlichen Existenz
[Musik]
unsere morphologischen Anpassungen
spiegeln lediglich wieder wo unsere
Vorfahren auf dem Planeten entstanden
sind wie viel Sonne bekamen sie wie viel
Sauerstoffe in der Luft sie bestimmen
die Form ihrer Schädel die Farbe Ihre
Haut aber das hat nichts mit dem Wesen
der Menschen zu tun damit was es
bedeutet ein Mensch zu sein weil wir
alle dieselbe Spezies sind
[Musik]
es war eine ziemlich wunderbare Reise
für die Menschheit aber junge was für
ein wunderbares Bündel von Themen mit
denen wir uns in Zukunft
auseinandersetzen müssen wir müssen
nicht dann mal nach Alpha Centauri
reisen um diese Themen zu finden und
etwas über uns selbst zu erfahren es
geht darum wie wir die langfristigen
Probleme angehen können wir die Weisheit
verkörpern von der wir glauben dass sie
hier in der rennt ist und Weise in die
Zukunft gehen
wenn wir in unserem Rat in on und AGA in
die Zukunft blicken wenden wir uns an
uns selbst und sagen es war ja nicht so
jenseits des Feuers es war ja nicht so
und ich fragte einen der alten
Häuptlinge meinen Onkel ich fragte was
bedeutet das eigentlich
er sagte es bedeutet die Anführer und
ich fragte nein nein wie lautet die
echte wörtliche Übersetzung er sagte es
bedeutet dass ICH und DU weit in die
Zukunft schauen
[Musik]
Astronaut Neil Armstrong der den
nächsten Schritt in der Evolution
unseres Wissens verfolgte als er von
einer der größten technischen
Errungenschaften der Menschheit
zurückkehrte erklärte ich war der
Meinung dass die erfolgreiche
Mondlandung die Menschen auf der ganzen
Welt inspirieren könnte zu glauben dass
unmögliche Ziele möglich sind das ist
wirklich Hoffnung für die Zukunft der
Menschheit gibt
wir leben in der Vergangenheit der
Zukunft die relativen Chancen für
zukünftige Ergebnisse ändern sich jede
Sekunde die Welt in der wir alle leben
ist nicht größer als die Summe ihre
einzelnen Teile
jedes Teil ist weder das Zentrum noch
der Rand
es ist eine belebte Welt ein Haushalt
von Wesen
Kollegen sowohl menschliche als auch
nicht menschliche belebte und unbelebte
auf die wir Einfluss haben die aber
ihrerseits uns beeinflussen
physische Realitäten existieren
unabhängig von unseren Wünschen
scheinbar unbedeutende Handlungen die
wir gemeinsam unternahmen haben uns zu
diesem Moment geführt
alles ist ein System von Beziehungen
und es ist nicht leicht die
Zusammenhänge zu erkennen
die Verbindungen zwischen der Farbe auf
einer Scheune
den gleichgültigen Asphalt einer
Pressekonferenz oder die unsichtbaren
Verbindungen zwischen den menschlichen
Erwartungen zu sehen
menschliche Verletzlichkeit
menschliches Gedächtnis
und die Zerbrechlichkeit des Lebens
selbst
nein er ist erfordert Anstrengung
[Musik]
Energie gibt es in vielen Formen
sie ist sowohl Mittel als auch Zweck all
unserer Bestrebungen
wir alle werden von der Atmosphäre in
den Arm genommen
wir müssen keine Dichter Wissenschaftler
Superhelden oder heilige sein
jeder von uns kann darüber nachdenken
wie wir denken
könnte die Lösung nach der wir suchen in
uns selbst liegen
wir sind Menschen
[Musik]
Einfallsreichtum liegt in unserer DNA
und wir können visualisieren
welche Art von Zukunft wünschen sie sich
was sind Sie bereit beizutragen um diese
Zukunft zu gestalten
fragen Sie sich was bin ich bereit zu
tun
nicht etwas das Meer Aufwand erfordert
als sie bereit sind zu leisten aber auch
nicht nur ein kleiner Beitrag der an den
Schuldgefühlen kratzt aber nicht
zielführend ist nein fragen Sie sich was
bin ich bereit beizutragen das für mich
selbstverständlich ist etwas dass ich
durchhalten kann bis die Herausforderung
bewältigt ist etwas das in mein Leben
passt mein Beruf meine Hobbys das zu
meinen Beziehungen passt
etwas das ein Teil dessen ist was ich
bin
wissen sie jeder von uns ist einzigartig
jeder von uns hat eine Gabe eine Stärke
die wir lenken können um diese Welt zu
schaffen die wir uns für unsere Zukunft
wünschen
die wir uns für die Zukunft unserer
Kinder und Nachkommen wünschen
wir leben unsere Kinder nicht wahr
da fällt mir ein Zitat des religiösen
Philosophen Pierre Teller der Schande
ein
nachdem wir die Winde die Wellen und die
Gezeiten die Schwerkraft gemeistert
haben werden wir für Gott die Energie
der Liebe nutzbar machen
und dann zum zweiten Mal in der
Geschichte der Welt
wird der Mensch das Feuer entdeckt haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]